[Music]
that first experience and this posture
that are not the sole postulates but a
whole circle of postulates opens up
nature that is to say is not merely this
wholly free external mode of being in
which as a pure object consciousness had
to realize its purpose this
consciousness is in its own self
essentially one for which this other
free actual existence is that is it is
itself a contingent to natural existence
this nature which is for consciousness
its own nature is sensuousness which in
the shape of Alishan as instincts and
inclinations possesses a specific
essentiality of its own or has its own
individual purposes and thus as opposed
to the pure will and its pure purpose
however in contrast with this opposition
pure consciousness has rather the
relation of sensuousness to it the
absolute unity of the latter with it for
its essence
both of these pure thought and the
sensuous aspect of consciousness are in
themselves a single consciousness and it
is precisely pure thought for which and
in which this pure unity is but qua
consciousness what is explicit for it is
the antithesis of itself and impulses
and instincts in this conflict between
reason and sensuousness the essential
thing for reason is that the conflict be
resolved the result being the emergence
of the unity of both a unity which is
not the former original that is
immediate unity of both in a single
individual but a unity which proceeds
from the known antithesis of both only
such a unity is actual morality for in
it is contained the antithesis whereby
the self is consciousness or first is an
actual self in fact and at the same time
a universal in other words in that unity
there is expressed that mediation which
as we see is essential to morality sense
of the two moments of the antithesis
sensuousness is sheer other Nisour the-
while on the other hand the pure thought
of duty is the essence no element of
which can be given up it seems that the
resultant unity can only be brought
about
by getting rid of sensuousness but since
sensuousness is itself a moment to the
process producing the unity that is the
moment of actuality we have to be
content in the first instance with
expressing the unity by saying that
sensuousness should be in conformity
with morality this unity is likewise a
postulated being it is not actually
therefore what is there is consciousness
or the antithesis of sensuousness and
pure consciousness but at the same time
the unity is not an in itself or merely
implicit like the first postulate in
which free nature constitutes an element
of the unity and in consequence the
harmony of nature with the moral
consciousness falls outside of the
latter on the contrary nature here is
that which is an element of
consciousness itself and we have here to
deal with morality as such with a
morality that is the act of self very
own consciousness has therefore itself
to bring about this harmony and
continually to be making progress in
morality but the consummation of this
progress has to be projected into a
future infinitely remote for if it
actually came about this would do away
with the moral consciousness for
morality is only moral consciousness as
negative essence for whose pure duty
sensuousness has only a negative
significance is only not in conformity
with duty but in that harmony morality
qua consciousness that is its actuality
vanishes just as in the moral
consciousness or in the actuality of
morality the harmony vanishes the
consummation therefore cannot be
attained but is to be thought of merely
as an absolute task that is one which
simply remains a task yet at the same
time its content has to be thought of as
something which simply must be and must
not remain a task weather we imagine the
moral consciousness to be altogether
done away with in this goal or not
which of these really is the case can no
longer be clearly determined in the dim
remoteness of infinity to which for that
very reason the attainment of the goal
is postponed strictly speaking we shall
have to say that a definite idea
this point ought not to interest us and
ought not to be looked for because it
leads to contradictions the
contradiction of a task which is to
remain a task and yet want to be
fulfilled and the contradiction of a
morality which is no longer to be a
moral consciousness that is not actual
however the idea that a perfected
morality would involve a contradiction
would do harm to the sanctity of the
very essence of morality and absolute
duty would appear as something unreal
paragraph 603 is another one of these
very very long passages within the
phenomenology and there's quite a bit
going on here but we could sum it up by
saying that there's a double problematic
that is being exposed and not completely
resolved here one of which is how things
can be held within the same
consciousness and this is not just a how
but a they actually are held within the
same consciousness so it's not a
question of how we get from point A to
point B when we're stuck at point a
we're already at point B and we're
wondering how did we get here
how is this actually possible the second
part has to do with what it means for
something to be postulated set out there
as a requirement or a demand on the part
of thought or consciousness when in
actuality what we are experiencing is an
antithesis so how do we move from the
antithesis to what Hegel here is terming
a unity so let's take a look jump right
into the text since there's so much of
it that we need to go through so in the
the previous paragraph 602 we saw that
it wasn't so easy to say that Duty could
simply be opposed to happiness for the
individual who is attempting to do his
or her moral duty that in fact there is
a postulated or required but not yet
actual or realized harmony and that's
the term Hegel is using there before a
harmony of nature and morality or nature
and/or
morality and happiness here he says that
first experience and this postulate are
not the sole postulates but a whole
circle of
postulates open up so now the problem is
getting deeper than it had been before
or if not deeper it is actually deeper
at least more complicated because there
are more figurative balls in the air
being juggled around in the dialectic
so he says nature that is to say is not
merely this wholly free external mode of
being we saw that that before nature is
a realm of freedom but is is a freedom
that at this point is alien to the
freedom of the human being as moral
creature is moral self maker he says
it's not merely this wholly free
external mode of being in which as a
pure object consciousness had to realize
its purpose what is it that this
consciousness he says is in its own self
essentially one for which this other
free actual existence the actual
existence of nature nature we're in the
environment nature know within the
nature of the human being
so this consciousness is essentially one
for which this other actual free
existence is that is he says it is
itself a contingent and natural
existence every one of us is a
contingent and natural existence what
does that mean a natural existence and
we're going to get into this in just a
moment means that we are bodily for
example you know you can say well I'm
not sure with a you know resolution to
the hard problem of consciousness is you
know am I my body and my mind how's the
mind the body connected blah blah blah
blah blah don't worry about that at this
point just take stock of the fact that
you do in fact have this body and with
that comes a certain way of being
actually many ways of being and you do
in fact have a mind or our mind and
along with that isn't just pure thought
thinking itself or anything like that as
a matter of fact
that's pretty rare a little bit of a
digression here Rene Descartes who many
people imagine as you know somebody
who's doing philosophy all the time off
by himself in his stove heated room you
know thinking to himself carrying about
this you know amazing mental process of
abstracting away everything of the body
and extension and the senses and just
concentrating his intellect on you know
the purity of thought Rene Descartes
says in a letter man you can do that
maybe a month or you can do that maybe
an hour out of a month or a year most of
the time we are in fact thinking through
if not our bodies I mean we're thinking
through our brains in large part we're
thinking through our imagination not a
pure intellect and we are individualized
we are individuals we have these drives
and inclinations instincts that's part
of what it means to be an individual
human being so he goes on and he says
well before that contingent what does it
mean for us to be a contingent existence
contingent means that things could be
otherwise I am Who I am in the way that
I am at this point in time but that is
itself the product not only of
environmental factors or genetics but
also my own choices and the choices of
other people how they've impacted on me
all of that could be very very different
I don't have to be before you giving you
this lecture at this point in time about
Hegel I don't have to have ever
encountered Hegel in my lifetime I could
be sweeping a floor right now I could be
dead at the bottom of a trench I could
be a million different things but I
happen happens to have fallen out this
way that's what contingent comes from
cadre in Latin things happen to have
fallen out that way things wound up like
that that's the way my existence is and
much of what I'm concerned
our other contingencies that are going
to be going on for the rest of my life
so what does this pan out with he says
this nature which is for consciousness
its own nature hearing introduces a new
term is sensuousness Xin Li kite this is
in many respects a technical term which
you're going to find used in philosophy
when we distinguish between our rational
or intellectual side and the side of
sense often this is tied in with
distinctions between mind and body or
the mental and the corporeal
it's not just in in German it's also you
know found in the Latin philosophers the
Greek philosophers is going to be found
in French it's gonna be found in English
you're gonna find this distinction
invoked all over the place even by those
who are essentially materialists will
distinguish between the sensuous bodily
and that of the mind the soul the sookay
all right so sensuousness what does that
translate into he says he says in the
shape of volition we're gonna come back
to that shape in a moment as instincts
and inclinations possesses a specific
essentiality of its own or has its own
individual purposes and thus as opposed
to the pure will and it's pure purpose
so let's unpack this we have instincts
being translated here FIBA we could also
translate that just as well as is done
in the psychoanalytic literature as
drives played means Drive instinct work
so right for that it's something that we
have implanted within us and we become
conscious of it as moving us towards
some things away from other things
inclinations noggin literally like you
know we we lean towards some things and
go away from other things inclinations
works for that now why is this important
let's dwell for just a second on this in
the previous paragraph we saw that there
is this conflict not just between nature
and morality but between happiness
glueck leak-tight and morality the way
that can't define happiness in that
sense is the satisfaction of all of our
desires and inclinations all of the
things that we find ourself wanting it
and also we could add the negative to it
not getting the things that we don't
want so this really is about what we
think or feel or at this point in time
are convinced is going to make us happy
what happiness consists in for us Hegel
says this is something as individuals we
certainly have a almost immediate
relationship with often winds up being
more complicated than that
when we actually get what we want or if
we think about how to get what we want
but well let's say that for the moment
now the other thing I wanted to point
out here is he says in the shape of
volition he's using the word Gestalt
here now why is that important because
Gestalt Dez Babu signs is shape of
consciousness and we know that the
Hegelian dialectic is in fact this
entire succession of shapes of
consciousness developing out of previous
shapes of consciousness through you know
an antagonistic and dialectical and
recuperative process into new shapes so
we have a shape of consciousness here on
this side I don't think that we should
just say shape we should think of this
as a shape of consciousness now he also
says that it possesses a specific
essentiality of its own its own
individual purposes its own individual
Zak right we saw that vacker purpose was
very important for the moral
consciousness so we're developing this
entire side
of nature the nature of the human being
in this first part of the paragraph then
he changes things up says in contrast
with this opposition pure consciousness
has rather the lay the relation of
sensuous sensuousness to it the absolute
unity of the latter with it for its
essence here's where we get to that big
theme that I was talking about as the
first one that this paragraph is raising
both of these pure thought on the one
side and the sensuous aspect of
consciousness on the other side are in
themselves in a single consciousness and
he says and it is precisely pure thought
for which and in which this pure unity
is now here we get to a very interesting
problematic I as the moral consciousness
as the human being conscious of being
bound by or being obligated or
recognizing certain moral duties and
both sides a little bit later Hegel is
going to present this in terms of the
individual being aware that he or she is
also at the same time a universal so
this did get very much problematized
within cons philosophy and Hegel is
taking this up here if you look at the
groundwork of the metaphysics of morals
and you look not just at the first two
sections but the third session in which
we're moving into the new minoo and
trying to understand the very basis of
human freedom that's all on this side
right this is where the pure will is
here Hegel talks later about reason but
we could also put pure will on here as
well and remember the will for Kant is
in fact practical reason the will can
choose whether it is pure practical
or whether it's going to be bound by
sensuousness in which case it works in a
essentially mechanistic fashion being
given its Zach its end its goal and then
just finding the way to that goal so
there's a very interesting background
here the question is how do I hold these
together in my thought at the same time
now one he's got a suggestion that's
being offered to us that happens on this
side the side of pure thought that's
what makes sense out of it and if you
look at the history of morality up until
this point whether we're looking at in a
Cartesian fashion or a human fashion or
in Consuelo I mean there's a few
exceptions to this it's usually the
thinking part of us that's going to work
out all of this the thinking part
understands the sensuous part the
sensuous part does not understand the
thinking part Hegel is going to try to
get us beyond this he says where I
rather he's going to try out a process
by which humankind actually went beyond
this he says quant consciousness what is
explicit for it is the antithesis of
itself and impulses and instincts so he
says we've got a conflict here between
reason and sensuousness the essential
thing for this reason is that the
conflict being resolved the result being
the emergence of a unity of both a unity
which is not the former original unity
of both in a single individual but a
unity which proceeds from the known
antithesis of both so this is well worth
dwelling upon it's not a unity that you
can just assume and say well look
they're both in the human beings so
somehow it must all work out that is not
the case anybody who's ever experienced
a genuine crisis of conscience knows
that there can be a terrible conflict
within us between duty and sensuousness
or happiness or nature right so how
can we in fact attain this unity this is
where in typical Hegelian fashion it
cannot just be a unity that reconciles
everything places everything into its
proper pigeonhole and then tells you you
know go there for this sort of thing go
there for this sort of thing
we can't just divide the entire moral
world up into what falls on this side
and what falls on this side it is a
project yet to be attained and it's one
that has to take into account the full
antithesis or Gagan Zots the
contradiction between duty morality on
one side and happiness or our
inclinations and drives instincts
volition sensuousness on the other side
so he says only such a unity is actual
veer Cleef morality for Unidas contain
the antithesis whereby the self is
consciousness or first is an actual self
in fact and at the same time a universal
that's the passage that I brought up
earlier we are at the same time a
universal sort of stand-in for everybody
everybody should behave the way that I
do everybody should understand as I do
and we are an individual and the
individuality is the basis for us even
being conscious in the first place so he
goes on and he says in that unity
there's a mediation which is essential
to morality a mediation essential to
morality keep that thought in your mind
so then it says all these two moments of
the antithesis sensuousness is sheer
other nests or the- pure thought of duty
is the essence no element of which can
be given up it seems that the resultant
unity can be brought about by getting
rid of sensuousness this is one of the
ways in which we try to do it one way in
which that happens is you say
sensuousness that's just this
mechanistic world outside that's the
phenomenal world that we're caught up in
just resist it you know don't take any
cues from it don't even exercise
prudence or pay attend
- you know these general imperatives
which are still yet hypothetical just
happens they apply to everybody every
human being who ever existed
this is Kant in the groundwork of the
metaphysics of morals that's one way to
do it
Hegel does not think that's going to
work he goes on and he says since
sensuousness is itself a moment of the
process producing the unity since it's
there and it's part of the process we
can't get rid of it we have to be
content with expressing the unity by
saying here's another possibility saying
that sensuousness should be in
conformity with morality morality once
again supervenes on the sensuousness
guides it tells it how it ought to
behave okay is that going to settle
things for us now here's where he he
brings in postulation again says that
unity is likewise a postulated being
it's not actually there it doesn't yet
exist what is there he says well
conscious consciousness the antithesis
of sensuousness and pure consciousness
being conscious of this conflict within
one's own consciousness and of the fact
that you're stuck with these two you
know and Hagen istic forces or aspects
or whatever they are within you because
they are you you can't get away from
them you cannot escape this antithesis
so he goes on and he says this unity is
not an in itself or merely implicit like
the first postulate and which free
nature constitutes an element of the
unity and in consequence the harmony of
nature with the moral consciousness
falls outside on the contrary something
different is happening here right nature
is that which is an element of
consciousness itself here we have to
deal with morality as such a morality he
says that is the active self
very own we cannot eliminate or
subordinate either side they are both
equally what we are they both equally
though in different ways make a
contribution to the very possession of
moral consciousness as an individual
which is the only way that I can have
moral consciousness as this individual
who I am
so he says consciousness therefore has
to bring about this harmony and
continually be making progress in
morality that's worth dwelling upon it
has to continually make progress in
morality that means that morality is not
something that we attain as a finished
state where we've again to use the
metaphor checked off all the boxes well
or didn't lie I fulfilled all my
promises I show gratitude to those who
are benefactors to me I distributed
things justly you know we that's not at
all the way morality really works it's
more like a constant challenge we're
like each day you'd have to be like you
could do the checklist you could say
well I didn't lie to anybody although I
sure as hell was tempted to lie in this
circumstance got to work on that I could
have been better in distributing
resources justly there was a situation
there that was a bit you know complex
and I think I might have made a wrong
snap decision about that I'll have to
reassess that and maybe see if I can fix
that in the morning and go on and on and
on like that we never actually reached
the limit point where there is a genuine
unity or harmony integrating all of
these things together completely so he
says the consummation of this progress
has to be projected notice where it's
projected into a future infinitely
remote
now here's an interesting thing to say
if it did come about this would do away
with the moral consciousness why would
it do away with the moral consciousness
because then there would no longer be
this conflict or antithesis or
contradiction between sensuousness or
nature and pure thought of duty Kant
does in fact consider something like
this within his book religion within the
limits of reason alone in talking about
the genuinely good pure will the holy
will that is really not for us it's
something we can strive towards but it's
not our condition so why does Hegel say
that morality the moral consciousness
would go away he says morality is only
moral consciousness as negative essence
for who's pure duty sensuousness has
only a negative significance is only not
in conformity with duty so in that
harmony he says morality qua
consciousness that is its actuality
vanishes just as in the moral
consciousness or in the actuality of
morality the Harmony vanishes so that's
a little bit of a complicated sentence
let's take another second part first the
harmony in actual morality as we're
living it out in our day-to-day life
making decisions trying to fix the screw
up so you've done with those decisions
afterwards is a constant process of
trying to figure out how we reconcile
these things that seem to be basically a
bad fit with each other and they're all
stuck within our consciousness if we did
in fact reconcile all this sort of stuff
we would lose the moral consciousness
Hegel says it would no longer with us
but it would no longer be moral
consciousness so he says this
consummation cannot be attained but it's
to be thought of as an absolute task one
which remains a task now this is a
problem right because from the Hegelian
perspective anything that can't be made
actual is deficient in some way
so he says its content has to be thought
of as something which simply must be and
must not remain a task here's the
postulation coming back again whether we
imagine the moral consciousness to be
all together done with the done away
with in this goal or not so where are we
left here he tells us which of these
really is the case can no longer clearly
be determined in the dim remoteness as
he says of infinity to which for the
attainment of the goal is postponed
strictly speaking we have to say that a
definite idea on this point ought not to
interest us all I'm not to be looked for
because it leads to contradictions the
contradiction of a task which is to
remain a task and yet ought to be
fulfilled right there's a paradox there
it's a task that ought to remain a task
and it also ought to be fulfilled which
value are we going to have for it if you
attain it then it still has to be
fulfilled if it still has to be
fulfilled it's to be fulfilled by
actually attaining it he says the kind
there's also a contradiction of a
morality which is no longer to be a
moral consciousness that is not actual
now notice when he's saying not actual
for Hegel morality is not attained just
when everything is being done the right
way we have to be conscious of doing
things the right way because we choose
to do them the right way and we
recognize the moral values that require
us to go against those sides of our self
that stand in the way of it there must
be you might say resistance a resistance
that comes out of our very individuality
to the universality of morality or else
we do not have moral consciousness we
just have a realization of a moral state
of affairs which is no longer morality
so he finishes up here by saying the
idea of perfected morality would involve
a contradiction would do harm to the
sanctity of the very essence of morality
an absolute duty would appear as
something unreal so we not only have
these contradictions at this level there
is a meta contradiction of wait a second
morality is something
rational shouldn't be beset with all
these contradictions can we find a way
out of them that's what we're going to
see in the paragraphs to come
you